this is Justin standing in for Cali play
ease destiny to cursive Osiris review in
progress if you simply ran out of things
to do in vanilla destiny - its first DLC
expansion curse of Osiris and a few new
activities for you to take on for the
most part though there isn't enough in
the expansion yet to justify coming back
our opinion is still in flux since we
haven't played the raid layer yet but so
far the story missions strikes new
crucible Maps and adventures feel like
more of the same
despite the DLCs new settings and
stories person Osiris picks up right
after the end of the first base games
campaign as far as your level goes you
could go directly from the end of the
red war story to curse of Osiris his
campaign which requires a power level of
200 to 220 without having to grind too
much in between for newcomers or PC
players who've had less time with the
game it's a comfortable bridge for
leveling up between the lower level
vanilla content and the high level
in-game activities like the nightfall
and those in-game activities by the way
are a different story we'll get into
that in a bit as a result though curse
of Osiris's story missions feel like
filler the campaign sets up an enormous
undertaking against effects with
infinite timelines and computer
simulations and the mysterious Warlock
Osiris mixed up at at all but with a 2
or so hour runtime the missions rush
through the interesting concepts and
usher you into a simple final battle
that's essentially scripted it's also
not enough time to fully understand
Osiris as a character which is
disappointing considering he's only ever
been mentioned in destiny lore before
now I've studied all of us irises
writings and written five works
exploring his wisdom the beautifully
designed at varied infinite forest of ex
creation designed to simulate timelines
and their infinite permutations is the
most interesting addition in the
expansion but even then the story
doesn't task you with exploring it
instead shepherding you through areas to
find codes and things that smarter NPCs
can use to pinpoint your next
destination for you
scanning I can't find cannot see the
maps too big wait I've got something
coordinates weren't no to the infinite
forest I'm getting an image but no
coordinates
I'm not ideas here look I can't decrypt
those files or over the game other than
the infinite forest the new destination
mercury is simply uninteresting to
explore it's a small circular map with
one new public event to try out a new
vendor a handful of chests and the lost
sector the foundation of exploration
established in the base game is still
good here having a variety of options to
choose from does make things feel less
repetitive but it feels like busywork
with little to do at the highest level
that extends to the new strikes which
are almost direct copies of two of the
story missions nothing more than another
way to kill time the biggest problem
with cursive osiris is that it locks the
hardest activities including the
prestige nightfall and the prestige raid
behind its new power level cap the
recommended power for those activities
is 3:30 which you can't reach if you
don't have the curse of osiris dlc so if
you don't get the dlc you suddenly don't
have access to something you used to be
able to do it's also frustrating if you
do get cursive Osiris because the higher
level requirement doesn't fundamentally
change those activities new heroic
adventures at nightfall style modifiers
to the adventures on Mercury but those
missions aren't begging to be replayed
the main incentive to do it all is to
unlock the lost prophecy quest from the
NPC brother Vance which eventually
unlocks to forge from there you can
craft legendary vex weapons but for
anyone besides the most dedicated
players there's no compelling reason to
do all this unless you want to redo old
missions on harder difficulties in order
to get loot to use when you do them
again because the main reward for
everything you do is shiny new loot the
frustratingly high drop rate of
duplicates makes grinding more
disappointing than satisfying the
gunplay feels as great as ever though so
it can be fun to experiment with new
weapons but it's not enough to sustain
an expansion that adds little outside of
extra busywork
that being said we still need more time
to try out the lost prophecies the Forge
and the raid lair if they provide more
of an endgame and have more of a purpose
than just patting out the same kind of
stuff then we might be more inclined to
return to destiny - look I can't decrypt
those files or over the gate we need
backup
we need a Korra good idea